la nomination d'enabré comme premier
ministre tchadien a été généralement
bien accueilli à njanema la capitale
bien accueilli aussi à Paris où on
estime qu'elle constitue je cite
l'Élysée une étape importante dans le
processus d'unification du Tchad et
l'acheminement vers la paix Paris où on
est donc tout disposé à oublier les
moments les plus pathétiques de la
captivité de Madame clustre nous voyons
là la le versement de la première rançon
à l'ancien chef des rebelles Toubou il
faut dire que le président français a
fait beaucoup pour aider à la
réconciliation des différentes ethnies
au Tchad la France qui est largement
engagée là-bas il n'est qu'à voir le
poids des coopérant et de l'armée vous
propose un reportage de Jacques
abouchard et de
jean-lebert 800 km de njamena les avions
militaires débarquent quotidiennement
vivres et munitions sur la piste
d'abécher c'est le ravitaillement
destiné à la garnison tchadienne
renforcé par quelques 500 soldats
français de l'infanterie marine équipé
d'automitrailleuse abécher est l'un des
verrous du dispositif militaire
franco-chadien face aux forces rebelles
du Front de Libération Nationale le
frelina pourtant la population d'abécher
un gros bourg agricole n'a jamais caché
sa sympathie pour la rébellion au point
que les coopérants français des
professeurs et des médecins sont tous
partis il y a quelques mois à une
exception près il est vrai un seul de
nos compatriotes civils a refusé
l'évacuation c'est un ecclésiastique le
révérent père d'amont vous ne vous
sentez pas
menacé la question je regarde pas la
question sous cet angle là je dois que
je reste et puis c'est tout peut-être il
y a-t-il des dangers les autres
Européens sont partis faut dire que
l'ambassade est venue les chercher
certains sont partis un peu auparavant
devant les une certaine explosion
populaire et certains avaient peur ici
donc les gens sont prof frolina ici la
majorité de la population est
sympathisante au frolina ici l'armée
française est considérée comme une armée
étrangère d'occupation comme une armée
d'occupation la zone rebelle n'a pas
cessé de s'agrandir au nord du Tchad
toutes les garnisons tenues par l'armée
tchadienne sont tombées comme un jeu de
kille barda juillet 77 Fargeot février
78 Salah Arada avril
78 le premier coup d'arrêt a été donné à
jeda en mai dernier pour la première
fois des renforts français fraîchement
débarqués était engagé le frolina a
perdu 200 hommes dans la
bataille selon les officiers français
les forces adverses étaient parfaitement
aguérri et Mané avec aisance leur
armement lourd d'origine
soviétiquee un mec qui embque ti
papa
les rebelles ont d'ailleurs fait mouche
à deux reprises ces derniers mois contre
des jaguars dont une escaderie et basé
un
jamena est-ce que vous pensez que la
présence militaire pour vous est une
bonne chose pour votre sécurité la
présence militaire
française c'est une arme à double
tranchant c'estd c'està-dire que la
présence de militaire c'est
naturellement la protection mais c'est
peut-être aussi la dégradation des
rapports avec les Tchadiens les
Tchadiens avec nos autres vous senté une
dégradation je pense qu'il faudrait
être soit naïf soit hypocrite pour ne
pas le
constater au Tchad les 2 tiers de la
population sont islamisé et la rébellion
née chez les Toubou a constamment joué
de l'antagonisme entre musulmans du Nord
et animistes ou chrétiens du du Sud la
Libye qui soutient le frolina n'a fait
qu'exacerber ce sentiment l'Arabie
saoudite a offert cette somptueuse
mosquée de njamena la plus belle
d'Afrique noire coû 6 milliards de
centimes la réconciliation nationale
prenée par le général Maloum passe aussi
par la fin de l'antagonisme religieux
l'armée aurait pu favoriser cette
réconciliation
elle n'a été que l'instrument au service
d'un clan aujourd'hui ce qu'il reste de
l'armée tchadienne est en recyclage sous
la conduite d'officiers français ce
travail que vous faites ici est-ce que
les officiers chadiens n'étaient pas
capable de le faire bien je pense je
suppose que si on m'a envoyé c'est qu'il
y avait une raison en fait les officiers
de chaduin sont occupés essentiellement
dans le nord du territoire leur armée
n'est pas très nombreuse et il était
évident que pouvant être à la fois au
four et au moulin il fallait que
quelqu'un fasse l'inruction dans le sud
du territoire ce que je fais à l'URE
actuel à SAR le problème de l'armée
tchadienne n'est pas mon affaire moi je
j'instruis des recruses et j'essaie de
former des soldats et qui sont qui font
je pense de bons soldats d'ailleurs vous
savez il a les mêmes soldats quand ils
ent entre les mains de ce qu'on a des
troupes des ex troupes coloniales on
fait de très bonnes troupes par
conséquent il y a pas de raison que
ceuxl ne fassent pas de bon soldat bien
votre Affa mais c'est Guer de 14 hein ça
avec les armes automatiques vous n'iriez
pas loin il faut me desserrer ça
davantage alors vous recommencez en
desserrant allez relevez-moi tous ces
gens-là c'est bon
cet encadrement a éviter l'effondrement
de l'armée tchadienne dont la moitié des
effectifs sont hors de combat
prisonniers du frolina ou
déserteur bien évident que les civils
qui comptent rester sur place quelle que
soit la situation politique ne tiennent
pas à être mis dans même sac que l'armée
française car il passera pour
l'opposition actuelle pour des gens qui
ont bactisé qui sont suspect je su pas
un technicien militaire je ne pense pas
que puisse y avoir quelque chose tant
que troupes français sont là
aprè